look at how many apps I have I can't
handle another David delete half your
apps you haven't touched in months you
see something weird report it and give
us good data now most of the time that
weird thing is going to be an airplane a
balloon a drone or the things I think
we're going to be encouraging NASA to do
is actually develop apps for people's
cell phones so you see something have a
standard app that takes an image records
the metadata metadata's location time
that sort of thing and you see something
interesting and someone else 10 miles
away sees something interesting from a
different perspective that's the same
event and you've got four or five
observations we can combine them get
distance velocity acceleration look at
how many apps I have I can't handle
another app okay David I can't do your
job for you you've got a lot of apps
you're not using Starbucks it's my
drizzly app delete half your apps you
haven't touched in months